l allant plus loin qui continue place
aux matchs des idées à présent va
s'arrêter sur la situation des femmes en
entreprise
dix ans après la loi copé zimmermann qui
imposait des quotas de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration et de
surveillance
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir avant la parfaite
égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
les quotas on commence maintenant à en
parler pour les postes de direction
c'est la ministre elle-même elisabeth
moreno qui ne voient pas d'autre
solution pour faire bouger les lignes
elle l'a fait savoir hier chez nos
confrères du grand jury une proposition
loi et même dans les tuyaux on va en
parler avec nos invités pour savoir ce
qu'elle en pense d'abord les chiffres
avec sandra cercle concernant la parité
hommes femmes en entreprise
il y à du progrès mais du chemin reste
encore à parcourir pour nous mais plus
de femmes dans les instances dirigeantes
une seule solution selon elisabeth
moreno passer par des quotas aujourd'hui
seuls 25% des postes de direction sont
occupés par des femmes
qu'est ce que dit le forum économique
mondial qu'il va falloir attendre deux
cent cinquante sept ans au niveau
planétaire où 54 ans en europe pour
arriver à une juste parité entre les
femmes et les hommes si on ne légifère
pas et si on n'est pas plus dans la
sanction
une proposition de loi a été déposé à
l'assemblée nationale en ce sens pour
instaurer des quotas parmi les 10% de
postes à plus forte responsabilité la
loi copé zimmermann voter en 2011 a
permis de passer de 12 à près de 45 % de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration mais elle reste encore
aux portes du vrai pouvoir économique au
sein des grandes entreprises françaises
seuls 21 % de femmes occupent des postes
de direction
le président du medef regrette ce manque
de présence féminine sans pour autant
être favorable à l'extension des quotas
faut regarder ce qu'on appelle le vivier
notamment les 10 % des cadres dirigeants
parce que c'est quand on a suffisamment
deux femmes dans les cadres des rêves et
que naturellement elle intègre les
comités d'érection et qu'ensuite elles
deviennent dirigeante également
sceptique la sénatrice christine lagarde
estime qu' imposer des quotas et
inefficace il existe tout un tas de
secteurs de l'activité dans laquelle la
place des femmes est réduite à la
portion congrue et donc demain si on
demande que dans ces secteurs on est 40
à 50% de femmes dirigeantes
est ce à dire que toutes les femmes
seront dirigeante même celles qui n'en
auraient pas forcément les compétences
41 responsables de grandes entreprises
françaises viennent de s'engager à
atteindre avant 2030 un minimum de 30%
de femmes aux postes à responsabilité et
avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir marie virginie klein bienvenue vous
êtes directrice générale adjointe en
charge du digital au sein du cabinet de
conseil ten tilder pardon et vous et 10
présidente également de willa incubateur
de start up spécialisée dans
l'entreprenariat féminin marion barizey
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
secrétaire général du think tank le
millénaire adjointe au maire du xvème
arrondissement pour le groupe change et
paris en groupe plutôt classé à droite
on est bien d'accord des quotas de
femmes dirigeantes à respecter avec des
sanctions fortes à la clé marie virginie
clan vous êtes pour définitivement pour
effectivement dans un monde idéal il
faudrait pas de quotas mais là on l'a vu
avec la loi copé zimmermann les plus
tard ça marche c'est à dire que en 2010
il y avait 12 % de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration en 2021 on a
45% cette fois mais par contre le sujet
c'est que les conseils d'administration
honnêtement avoir des femmes dans les
conseils d'administrations c'est bien
mais ça ne suffit pas c'est de
l'affichage c'est presque un conte dans
un conseil d'administration les
décisions sont quasiment prise à
l'avance et c'est un peu comme des
chambres d'enregistrement
ce qui compte c'est d'être de mettre des
femmes est d'avoir des femmes là où les
décisions se prennent dans les comités
de direction
les comités exécutifs etc et c'est pour
ça que c'est très bien que cette loi
prennent des décisions très fortes et on
voit bien ce qui marche c'est la
sanction et la sanctions notamment
financières c'est à dire que là si les
entreprises ne respectent pas alors pas
tout de suite seulement je crois dans
huit ans la sanction financière serait
équivalent à 1 % delà de la masse
salariale mais je vais me permet d'être
un peu impertinente là dessus parce que
même là le sujet il n'est pas suffisant
c'est à dire que des sanctions et des
quotas ce n'est pas encore suffisant
pour vous alors c'est une étude c'est
une étape mais le vrai sujet c'est quand
est ce que les femmes auront des vrais
fonctions de dirigeantes de direction et
des fonctions suprêmes une seule femme à
la tête d'une entreprise du cac 40
chez angie elle est même pas présidente
elle est directrice générale dans la
nouvelle économie dans les start up il
ya moins de 10% de femmes parmi toutes
les start up fondée qui sont des femmes
dans le gouvernement
pardonnez-moi mais depuis lors des
réalités de l'histoire de france
jamais une femme n'a dirigé la france à
l'exception peut-être de catherine de
médicis mais ça remonte quand même un
certain taux peuple refuse par ailleurs
on est dans un gouvernement mixte
oui certes mais le président de la
république le premier ministre le
ministre de l'intérieur le ministre
l'économie est ce que ce sont des femmes
je crois pas les cercles fermés c'est ce
qu'a dénoncé aussi elisabeth moreno
d'ailleurs un dans une interview et et
le sujet il est là donc c'est très bien
de parler des quotas dans les conseils
d'administration mais il faut pas que
les femmes restent sur la deuxième ou la
troisième marche du podium
marion paris êtes vous du même avis de
cet avis si tranchée on peut le dire je
le rejoins sur quelques points où dans
le sens où ce qui manque aujourd'hui
dans la la mise en valeur des femmes
s'est pas uniquement des postes mais
c'est des gros modèles comme on le dit
en anglais d
et des modèles d'inspiration pour les
jeunes filles qu'elles puissent se
projeter finalement dans des postes des
fonctions qui aujourd'hui sont
majoritairement occupés par des hommes
de là à dire est ce que les quotas sont
la bonne solution pour 7 pour atteindre
cet objectif
c'est ça l'est dans un premier temps
mais l'avantagent l'utilité d'un quota
ne fonctionne réellement à long terme
que si on peut y mettre un terme
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
tendance à créer des quotas
et on a beaucoup de mal à revenir sur
ces délits mettre un terme parce que
justement à partir d'un moment où en est
la rive à recréer cet écueil équilibre
entre hommes et femmes dans les milieux
il ne devrait plus y avoir besoin d'une
imposition par le haut mais peut-être
que ça arrive peut-être que ça arrivera
la difficulté est politique
parce que revenir sur cette décision une
fois qu'on arrive à un quota que c'est
très très compliqué raisonnable de
revenir sur la loi zimmerman copé zimmer
magnifiquement qui impose 40 % quotas de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration la ministre moreno nous
dit en 2009 il y avait moins de 10 % de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
françaises
dix ans après après avec cette loi on
est passé à 45 % qu'est ce qu'elle dit
cette loi que quand on veut on peut
pourquoi ça a fonctionné parce qu'il y
avait des sanctions fortes
on en arrive à obtenir de plus grand
nombre et aujourd'hui on a aussi
toujours quelque part un phénomène qui
reste une culture qui reste masculine
c'est à dire que très souvent dans ces
contextes là quand un quota est imposé
le rôle des femmes est aussi diminué par
par réflexe parce qu'on s'est dit
qu'elle soit été émise là par défaut
parce qu'on avait besoin de mettre une
femme sur ce poste donc c'est du vernis
en fait ça apparaît les changements
culturels sont très longs et c'est pour
ça que finalement au delà de cet aspect
de quotas ce qui ce qu'il faudrait faire
c'est travailler véritablement sur
l'éducation et depuis le depuis le plus
jeune âge une étude de l' ocde montre
que des cinq ans les objectifs les
carrières dans lesquelles ce projet les
enfants sont déjà orientés vers des
rôles spécifiques différents déjà entre
les petits garçons et les petites filles
à partir de ce moment là on a ces
stéréotypes qui continue d'exister
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent dans la vie
professionnelle
si on ne travaille pas dès le plus jeune
âge
la sensibilité avec des modèles
inspirants pour les femmes également on
ne pourra pas mettre a beau mettre à
bout ces différences une très
concrètement fait comment adra
concrètement moi je pense qu'il faut une
en lui et ses côtés alors d'abord juste
pour la politique de quotas moi je pense
que c'est une politique de quotas est
mise en place justement pour être
temporaire personne ne parle de quotas
définitif et il faut bien un peu
rééquilibrer les choses pour qu'ensuite
ça se fasse naturellement et
spontanément et plus à deux pas de
femmes à des postes de direction plus
les femmes auront ce réflexe aussi de
voir dans les femmes d'aidé potentiel
personnes à venir après leur succéder
très concrètement les role model c'est
très bien c'est d'ailleurs très
anglo-saxon mais c'est pas ça qui fait
la différence donc très concrètement il
ya un problème fondamental les femmes
osent moins il faut quand même se
l'avouer se le dire je pourrais pas dire
si j'étais un homme mais un problème de
confiance en soi qui est très fort moi
je le vois avec toutes les
entrepreneuses qu'on accompagne
il faut leur dire deux fois plus qu'un
homme qu'elles peuvent il faut leur dire
qu'elles sont légitimes questions à
disposition également
donc c'est que cc éducation mais c'est
tellement ancré dans l'adn depuis je
sais pas combien de milliers d'années
que ça peut pas se corriger le terminal
en une génération
je sais pas si c'est un déterminisme je
suis je suis pas sociologue mais moi ce
que je constate sur le terrain j'ai pas
une posture d'intellectuel mais une
posture de femmes qui voit des femmes et
j'envoie des dizaines par semaine c'est
que il faut deux fois plus les pousser à
faire les choses quand on parle d'une
émission télé je suis désolé mais pour
qu'une femme accepte de faire un plateau
télé il faut inciter deux fois plus pour
que pour qu'un homme
aïe aïe ça je le rejoins affirmé oui
c'est un sujet que je comprends tout à
fait et c'est un et c'est un fait au
delà d'être un souci quotidien
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec cette
idée est globalement s'est montrée dans
beaucoup d'études
les femmes se sous-estiment à capacité
égale on veut on peut avoir une fille
qui est la première de la classe au
collège elle va toujours se considérer
probablement moins compétente que que le
garçon qui est peut-être quelques notes
en dessous donc c'est un c'est un
problème de rosa maia les au bluff et on
l'apprend
fondamentalement il ya un problème
d'éducation danse y voilà on apprend aux
petites filles à être sage discrète et
s'est dissipée et les garçons à explorer
à aller de l'avant
à partir de cette base là on ne peut pas
fondamentalement espérer avoir un
résultat différent
il ya dans ce sens quelque chose à faire
tant sur la manière dont on socialise
nos enfants que sur le fait de faire
venir des personnes extérieures à
l'école au sein de l'école pour montrer
ce que c'est que la vraie vie ce que
peuvent faire les femmes également sinon
très souvent on a encore une répartition
malheureux malheureusement très genre et
dans certaines fonctions
les premiers ou les les personnalités
avec lesquelles les enfants sont le plus
en contact ça va être les enseignantes
ont des maîtresses des grolles du tri
principalement des femmes les
accompagnantes le personnel de l'école
la cantine principalement des femmes
également ce sont déjà des postes qui
sont quand même assez limité il c'est
difficile de demander à des enfants de
s'exposer et de penser au delà de cette
box de cette diète déjà cet exemple là
au quotidien on va complètement changer
de sujet on va parler vaccination si
vous le voulez bien personne n'a pu
échapper aux applaudissements et aux
encouragements de l'exécutif après cette
vaste opération de vaccination du week
end je le rappelle 585 milles français
vaccinés en trois jours on a tous cru un
coup d'accélérateur un peu magique lé
nous ouvrir pour de vrai cette fois une
porte de sortie avant l'été est ce qu'on
s'est trompé alors je vais pas vous
poser la question à vous tout de suite
mais donne je vais d'abord la pause est
notre invité dans ce match c'est bernard
jomier bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de paris rapporteur de la
commission denquête qu'ovide au sénat et
médecins par ailleurs pour vous cela n'a
été qu'une opération de communication
des médecins et des pharmaciens vont
manquer de doses à cause de cette même
opération à laquelle on a assisté ce
week end
non j'espère ce n'était pas qu'une
opération de communication c'était très
bien de donner un
de fouet à la campagne de vaccination
une vacciner que beaucoup de français et
pu être vaccinés pendant ce week-end
mais la question bien sûr c'est derrière
de ne pas désorganiser les chaînes de
vaccination
donc les médecins généralistes ont été
appelés à mettre en oeuvre la
vaccination dans leurs cabinets donc ça
commence tout juste cependant le cabinet
où j'exerce la semaine prochaine y aura
60 doses qui seront livrés pour
plusieurs médecins et malheureusement il
ya soir la direction générale de la
santé a annoncé que la semaine suivante
les mais les pharmaciens ne pourront pas
commander les vaccins pour les médecins
et pharmaciens qui les commande pour les
médecins c'est un peu compliqué mais
c'est pas grave
donc on est on est dans une situation où
effectivement on craint que les semaines
qui viennent soit beaucoup plus
difficile et il faut éviter ce stop and
go vous savez il faut pas demander aux
médecins de mettre en place des
vaccinations dans leurs cabinets et
quinze jours après ne plus leur livret
de vaccins notamment parce que de
nouvelles proto de professions de santé
rentrer dans la vaccination en croit
qu'il faut procéder de façon ordonnée de
façon planifiée et donc c'est à ça que
j'appelle le ministère c'est tout le
monde souhaite que la vaccination à
évite qu'on vaccine au plus vite les
français il faut le faire avec un
minimum d'organisation et pas dans ce
chaos qui est dénoncée aujourd'hui par
leur des médecins et par l'ensemble des
organisations de la profession ce que
vous dites là ce soir avec nous qu'on
dit pas que c'est une opération de
communication va j'ai lu vos tweets
effectivement où vous parlez d'une
opération de communication vous parlez
de chaos comme vous venez de le dire et
dans mépris gouvernemental pour pour les
médecins quand même oui un mépris enfin
caen rappelez vous il ya encore quelques
jours
il y avait sept accusations du
gouvernement sa pensée ce n'est pas
autre chose envers les soignants qui ne
voudrait pas se faire vacciner je
rappelle juste qu'ils encourent trois
semaines
les soignants de moins de 50 ans n'était
pas autorisé à se faire vacciner et donc
moins gelé et et parce que j'ai plus de
50 ans mais dont cali dans le cabinet où
j'exerce de mai
mais qui ont moins de 50 ans n'ont pas
pu être vacciné est donc passé de 300 en
trois semaines d'une interdiction d'être
vaccinés à une injonction une
stigmatisation
franchement c'est du grand écart à ce
niveau là c'est vraiment pas acceptable
c'est pas respectueux pour les soignants
et là maintenant on a ce nouvel épisode
donc où après un week-end de vaccination
intense alors bien sûr ça a été utilisé
en communication soit vous lisez mes
tweets avec attention par le
gouvernement je ne reproche pas non mais
je vous reproche pas au gouvernement de
faire de la communication
s'il l'a fait à bon escient un civil
c'est normal qu'ils valorisent ces
actions le problème c'est qu'en derrière
ça désorganise la chaîne de vaccination
et ça ça n'est pas passé alors on a une
communicante quand même sur ce plateau
est évidemment vous n'hésitez pas à
réagir bernard jomier ainsi quelque
chose vous vous intéresse en plateau
marie virginie klès c'était une énorme
opération de communication ce week end
c'était une énorme opération de
communication mais là l'erreur c'est que
aujourd'hui toute décision qui
n'apparaît pas comme une décision
éclairée seulement à travers l'intérêt
sanitaire n'est pas une bonne décision
donc là je suis très sensible à ce qui
vient d'être dit notamment sur le stop
and go c'est à dire que le plaisir aux
médecins vacciner vacciner à bala
attention les vaccins vont être réservés
aux pharmaciens et vous reprendrez
seulement dans une semaine les
vaccinations ça ça donne ça donne du
grain à moudre à tous ceux qui justement
comment dire soupçonne le gouvernement
de n'agir que pour se donner raison sur
ces stratégies de communication il
aurait très bien pu dire la vaccination
en pharmacie dès débutera uniquement
dans une semaine quand il y aura
suffisamment de vaccins livrés et on ne
désorganise pas comme ça ce qui est déjà
mis en place notamment les médecins
généralistes vont déjà fixé des dizaines
de rendez vous pour leur éviter qu'elle
a été asséché un peu improvisé cette
opération aussi n'avaient pas anticipé
cela je pense vous soufflez pourquoi ils
ont fait désespérante non
parce que je pense qu'ils sont dans une
telle urgence permanente qu'ils ont une
telle dose de décisions à prendre de
façon urgente qui font des erreurs et
donc moi je croit plus vraiment à ce que
tout soit prémédité je pense qu'ils font
au mieux ils décident au mieux mais
après coup ils se rendent compte qu'en
fait ces décisions sont pas optimales
justement parce que quand on fait trop
de choix il ya des choix que qu'on fait
mal et là typiquement sur cette
opération entre qui en plus alimente une
espèce de compétition entre les
pharmaciens et les médecins généralistes
c'était clairement pas une bonne idée
le bernard jomier une réaction à ce qui
vient d'être dit oui alors c'est ça et
puis ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
l'ess est la conséquence de voir
toujours décider tout seul parce
qu'effectivement il ya énormément de
décisions à prendre comme vous l'avez
dit dans des délais relativement courts
mais si la décision était plus partagés
on n'en serait peut-être pas dans cette
répétition parce que ce n'est pas la
première fois
d'erreurs on a dit on avait pointé dans
le rapport la commission denquête cette
gestion qui est qui est très centralisé
et on avait appelé à ce que les acteurs
de santé les acteurs territoriaux soient
mieux en mieux associés alors on le voit
par ailleurs il ya du progrès puisque
sans la question l'adaptation
territoriale effectivement maintenant le
gouvernement est rentré dans une logique
plus adaptée au territoire
vous noterez calais il est très peu
rentrer dans cette logique concernant
les activités puisque en 1000 commerces
où effectivement il ya une allée gestion
plus adaptative on peut reparler des
activités culturelles ou là on est
toujours dans l'arrêt total de toute
activité qui n'est pas fondée sur des
questions sanitaires voilà donc il ya
aussi cette ce mode de gestion qui
produit ses effets la et les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets et
l'épisode d'hier aujourd'hui est tout à
fait désastreux pour la confiance des
médecins pour leur participation et donc
pour le dynamisme de la campagne de
vaccination ans marion parise et ses
terribles un énorme coup de
communication qui aurait pu très bien
fonctionné qui est en train de se
retourner contre c'est un peu de
l'histoire de la gestion du colis depuis
le début finalement avec le gouvernement
qui essaye de faire des coûts de
communication à chaque fois et qui se
publie totalement que derrière les faits
vont les rattraper et derrière on a des
français qui attendent leurs vaccins qui
attend et qui ont attendu leurs tests
qui ont attendu leur masque c'est
répétitif et dans ça je suis plutôt
d'accord avec monsieur sur le fait quoi
on n'est pas simplement devant une
erreur due à la pression mais devant un
défaut de fonctionnement de ce
gouvernement sur ce point là mais
au-delà de ça il faudrait peut-être
fentes et deux autres aspects qui sont
problématiques avec avec cette décision
c'est que pour les médecins on a une
impossibilité un manque de prévision de
prévisibilité sur la possibilité par
exemple de faire leur seconde dose pour
tous les actes pour tous leurs patients
qui ont été déjà vaccinées c'est qu'ils
se lancent à l'aveuglé là mais il sait
encore vraiment quand est-ce qu'ils vont
pas devoir sion sont menées dans le
doute sur les sur les
livraison des vaccins eu derrière
doivent s'adapter en conséquence
donc c'est à dire que les
potentiellement des patients vont se
retrouver à un moment et devoir essayer
de trouver un autre endroit un ne peut
être un autre médecin pour les vacciner
pour faire la deuxième dose ou trois
semaines quand même quatre semaines il
le deuxième problème c'est que à travers
ces actions là on favorise des publics
qui sont les publics qui sont encore
relativement valide et qui sont capables
de se rendre notamment dans les lieux de
vaccination que ce soit en pharmacie que
ce soit dans des vaccinodromes qui on
veut les appeler comme talent j'ai alors
que derrière justement les généralistes
ont un atout pour certains c'est qu'ils
peuvent aller jusqu'aux près des
patients qui ne peuvent pas quitter leur
appartement leur maison et ça représente
de plus en plus de personnes qui sont
laissés sans cet accès on ne peut pas on
ne paie pas les laisser de côté en ce
sens là la communication oui a fini par
faire défaut
et j'ajoute le dernier mot de gabriella
talent dans le parisien qui parle d'une
vaccination obligatoire plus que
possible pour les soignants s'ils
continuent à refuser de se faire
vacciner
là on est plus effectivement dans
l'argument de l'urgence marie-virginie
klein mais peut-être dans un problème
chronique vous
vous êtes d'accord avec ça le problème
c'est toujours le changement de pied 1
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de stabilité
dans les messages qui sont donnés par le
gouvernement au début c'était tout tout
ça elle devait être sur la base du
volontariat et comme personne ne le fait
on va le rendre obligatoire surtout pour
le personnel hospitalier qui quand même
à une peu si eux ne se vaccinent pas ils
vont pas forcément montrer l'exemple
pour que d'autres ensuite se vacciner
ils peuvent alimenter une espèce de
suspicion déjà forte chez les français
sur les vaccins il ya aussi le sujet la
céleste rasé n'est qu'à qui est
disponible en ce moment j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a pas mal qui
attend de l'autre faiseur et qui
préfèrent de se faire se faire vacciner
par le finder ou je ne sais quelle autre
laboratoire le russe va arriver personne
n'en voudra voilà donc donc il ya aussi
ce phénomène d'aidés soignants qui peut
être mieux informés que les autres
essayent d'attendre le vaccin qui leur
convient le mieux
donc ils vont rendre le vaccin
obligatoire pour que la règle soit la
même pour tous est finalement qu elles
soient indiscutables
elle est on va vers le troisième thème
ce soir et je vous remercie infiniment
bernard jaume i et d'avoir été
notre invité ponctuel dans ce match des
idées troisième thème avec vous mesdames
cette longue interview de françois
hollande dans le parisien pour défendre
l'institution judiciaire après les
critiques de nicolas sarkozy liée à sa
condamnation
ce que je n'accepte pas ce sont les
attaques répétées contre la justice et
son indépendance a dit l'ancien
président et au passage d'égratigner la
macro ni eric dupond moretti aurait dû
défendre immédiatement l'institution
judiciaire dit il je veux croire que le
président macron garant de son
indépendance rappellera ses principes
en tout cas moi je le fais est ce que
sur le fond il a raison mario parisé sur
le fond si on prend la justice dans son
ensemble ce qui n'est pas le cas dans le
sujet qui nous occupe
on peut on peut ouvrir la question c'est
vrai que la justice est dans une perte
de crédibilité globale vis-à-vis de tout
le monde
le cas spécifique du parquet national
financiers ne relève pas tout à fait des
même dynamique que le reste de l'organe
judiciaire
la question du parquet national financé
et qu'on est sur une institution qui
juge le particulièrement le domaine
politique
or le parc national financier est
rattaché et sous l'autorité
les magistrats sont sous l'autorité
directe du garde des sceaux
c'est un parquet qui a été créée par
françois hollande est normal qu ils le
défendent ça serait compliqué autrement
donc critiquer le pnf oui critiqué la
justice dans son ensemble là je sais ça
ce niveau il faut prendre les choses de
manière plus subtile plus fine pas on
peut même dire que toutes les critiques
sont juste en tant que tel sur le
parquet national financier il ya une
vraie question qui se pose parce qu'on
est sur un organe où finalement on a des
magistrats qui vont ouvrir l'enquète
enquêter sur des personnalités
politiques qui cette enquête va être
présenté devant un tribunal qui est
constituée de jeunes qui ont été formés
par la même école
donc on connaît les écoles elles ont
toujours un peu un esprit soit formatage
ou en tout cas un esprit de corps qui se
créent et derrière on a aussi des
critiques qui ont été émises sur cet
organe à part la cdh la crds nous dit
cohen des droits de l'homme oui la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
que le parc national financier ces
magistrats ne peuvent pas se constituer
comme un tribunal impartial et
indépendant
c'est qu'on a on a sincèrement des
doutes sur la sur cette question et ses
doutes ils ont été mis en valeur dans
deux cas après simon il ya l affaire
sarkozy récemment mais surtout sur le
cas de l'enquète qui a été ouverte
contre françois fillon en 2010 est
maintenant parce que à l'époque déjà la
procureure et la doublette eliane
houlette avait mis en avant enfin il
traita ont elles annoncé que l'année
dernière qu'il y avait une question des
pressions qui ont été faites et c'est
vrai que par rapport à n'importe quel
autre cas on n'a jamais vu une enquête
se déclenche et aussi rapidement sur la
base d'un article publié dans un journal
donc ça permet d'avoir des doutes sur le
pnf marie-virginie klein alors moi je
prends ma casquette vraiment de
communicante ce que fait françois
hollande n'a rien perdu de son sens
politique et ce qui fait là est
extrêmement malin puisqu'il fait une
chose c'est qu'il en basse
emmanuel macron tous les électeurs de
droite jugent enfin tous en tout cas la
grande majorité des électeurs de droite
jugent la décision qui a été prise quand
même trois ans de prison dont un ferme
pour nicolas sarkozy extrêmement lourde
emmanuel macron n'a pas condamné ni
lui-même ni aucun de ses ministres
nicolas sarkozy qui a lui a faibli dans
ses propos justement le parquet le pnf
bon il lui aurait même passé un coup de
téléphone et selon leur est il y aura
évidemment tout à fait il y aurait même
passé un coup de téléphone donc ce que
fait hollande c'est très simple il
embarrasse emmanuel macron pour lui le
piège voilà et le piège pour le pousser
à prendre parole sur ce sujet là or
emmanuel macron on sait très bien
françois hollande emmanuel macron s'est
pas non plus l'amour fou puisque c'est
pourquoi
il m'a empêché françois hollande de se
représenter et par ailleurs on sait très
bien qu emmanuel macron et nicolas
sarkozy ne s'entendent pas si mal donc
il le met dans une situation d'embarras
folle qui est finalement très maline
puisqu'il va devoir pousser emmanuel
macron à agir le français emmanuel mon
nom je pense que enfin je ne sais pas
nous verrons mais après 2,2 petite
remarque quand même c'est qu'en faisant
ça françois hollande ne fait que mettre
de l'eau au moulin de nicolas sarkozy
qui laisse entendre que le pnf n'a été
créé que pour lui nuire et donc à tous
et sarkozy ce qui pend cabinet noir de
françois hollande et l'autre marque
c'est que quand il fait ça pardon mais
il un peu un rôle encore de premier
secrétaire
les anciens présidents de la république
ne s'exprime que sur des sujets il est
fort l'institution judiciaire c'est
important c'est du niveau d'un shérif
d'état l'arrière pensée est trop
évidente
on va continuer de parler politique avec
un tout dernier petit thème le front
républicain qui a décidément du plomb
dans l aile après le dossier de
libération sur cet électorat de gauche
qui refuserait de voter emmanuel macron
deuxième tour en cas de duel face à
marine le pen voilà que les maquereaux
nist se pose aussi la question en tout
cas pour les régionales et les
départementales de juin le journal du
dimanche qui a consacré un article ce
week-end ces marcheurs qui ne veulent
plus du front républicain
certains membres de la majorité
réclament le maintien de leur liste au
second tour même en cas de menaces de
victoire du r'n pas de règle et
automatique a en effet confirmé
stanislas guérini ça vous êtes surprise
mario pariset ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
réellement surprenant dans le sens où
c'est une tendance globale qu'on voit
aujourd'hui avec avec le front
républicain c'est la fin il est en train
de s'éteindre
on sent en tout cas que il ya une
effritement qui cet effritement il
remonte pas uniquement il ya quelques
mois il remonte déjà à l'élection
présidentielle de 2017
lors de laquelle jean luc mélenchon
avait n'avait pas appelé à faire barrage
à marine le pen au second tour
donc on a déjà
les graines étaient déjà là aujourd'hui
ce qui accentue ce phénomène c'est qu'on
a un emmanuel macron qui est fragilisé
dans sa position vis-à-vis de marine le
pen car d'un côté sur la gauche il a
perdu la plupart des électeurs en
attaquant les libertés publiques sur la
droite il a perdu sur le plan de la
défense de l'ordre public et sur le plan
économique parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
quand même dans une des récessions les
plus marquées par dans cette crise
sanitaire mondiale et dont on a aussi
des aides économiques majeurs et qui
n'ont pas les violences mais mais le
fait est que c'est celle de rente ou
même un coup un montant de mes fesses à
mon ordi en dévalant la dette à un autre
en tout cas macro aujourd'hui n'est plus
un candidat qui paraît pouvoir faire
barrage à marine le pen et en instaurant
ce doute finalement il laisse aussi la
place potentiellement pour un candidat
de substitution et c'est ce n'est pas à
négliger
on ne peut pas totalement oublié cette
opportunité de droite ou de gauche je ne
prends pas parti et sur ce point là mais
aujourd'hui en étant mis sur la sellette
il pourrait ouvrir une dynamique pour un
autre candidat pour les élections
présidentielles à sa place à lui à sa
place à lui pourtant il est plutôt pas
mal dans les sondages les manuels
maintenant sa personne c'est moi je
pense que là cette histoire du front
républicain
d'abord elle ne s'enclencherait que en
cas de second tour pour l'instant on est
dans le premier tour et personne ne peut
dire ne peut dire on ne fait pas
campagne puisque toute façon il y aura
un front républicain ça ferait que
déstabiliser et découragé certains des
candidats
moi je pense qu'il ya aussi quelque
chose qui intéresse en arrière c'est le
sujet xavier bertrand donc tout ça est
né de du traumatisme de 2015 ou des
candidats de gauche ou du ou 2 ou 2 ou
des macros nice ont dû se ranger
derrière un candidat de droite
si on prend le cas de xavier bertrand
d'un côté il aura besoin de ce
rassemblement démocratique pour se faire
réélire très certainement et en parlait
il ya peut-être aussi lui un agenda
caché puisque personne
enfin on peut pas cacher c'est plus
caché d'ailleurs c'est vrai il a un
agenda donc
donc il ya aussi c'est à dire que cette
idée de pas de règle générale et on
verra au cas par cas et pour ference et
l'asie bertrand paye pas que lui
mais c'est pour ces pour c'est pour
faire en sorte que les décisions soient
prises cas par cas et en fonction de
l'état des choses après le premier tour
et c'est un petit je crois qu'il est
urgent d'attendre sur cette question
c'est un petit peu tôt pour parler de
front républicain dès le deuxième tour
imaginez c'est en juin
tout ce qui peut se passer d'ici là et
on n'est même pas encore sorti delà de
la crise du coc vide et merci à toutes
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées c'est la fin de cette émission
demain à ma place vous retrouvez talent
traduit à 18 heures et à 22h30 moi je
vous retrouverai mercredi dans un
instant auditions publiques invité ce
soir julien bayou secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts
et puis demain matin vous retrouvez
bonjour chez vous dès 7h30 au
rayonnement de génie recevra notamment
boris vallot qu'il porte parole du parti
socialiste et député des landes je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat
[Musique]